the price of prescription drugs is still
rising
and a new study finds that we here in
the u.s pay much more than
other nations alex backus has that story
bonnie arnold suffers from powerful
migraine headaches
i call them shotgun migraines because it
feels like i got shot in the head
adding to that pain is the price of the
prescription she needs to take
they told me it was going to be 600 just
for that month's supply
her story is common the rand corporation
analyzed prescription costs in 33
nations
including the u.s they found prices in
america
are 256 percent higher on average
the u.s is the only country out of all
of the all of those that we looked at
where drug companies have free reign to
set
drug prices andrew mulcahy from the rand
corporation
says other countries negotiate with drug
makers
but many u.s government programs can't
do that medicare is prohibited by law to
negotiate drug prices
another analysis finds major
pharmaceutical companies are raising
prices on more than
500 drugs this year that's a 4.6 percent
increase
overall many of those are brand name
drugs that companies have
exclusive rights to make as opposed to
generics
which is one area that is working in the
u.s
rand found america actually pays less
for generic drugs than
other countries the u.s back in the 80s
set up a framework to allow robust
generic competition it's
succeeded wildly there are efforts
underway to also bring down the cost of
brand name drugs
president trump signed executive orders
to lower some prices
the biden administration is now looking
at legislation
to cap price increases and allow
americans to buy prescriptions from
other countries
alex backus 8 news now